estelle vous vous êtes place du
trocadéro bonjour où a lieu un
rassemblement statique qui lui aussi
touche à sa fin prise de parole de
multiples et les manifestations parlent
tous d'une même voix ils refusent l
extension se passe sanitaire exactement
à maera dire non à l'extension du pass
sanitaires et à l'obligation à
l'obligation vaccinale pour certaines
professions
c'était le but de ce rassemblement alors
ils sont toujours tout même un plusieurs
milliers vous allez le voir sur ces
images de didier migaud à être
rassemblés donc sur cette place du
trocadéro sur l'estrade à des prises de
parole ont été organisées tout au long
de l'après midi il y a encore quelques
minutes et c'est florian philippot qui
s'exprimait sur cette estrade florian
philippot qui a organisé ce
rassemblement ici le président des
patriotes et ancien numéro deux du
rassemblement national et qui a appelé
au boycott du pass sanitaires et plus
généralement au boycott des lieux qu'il
oblige je proposais l'écouté et c'est
encore un semblant démocratie en france
les gens écouteront ce qui se passe le
conseil constitutionnel censurera ce
texte
et s'ils écoutent pas de toute façon on
organisera le blocage général du pays on
fera un boycott vacciner comme non
vacciner les gens n'utiliseront pas leur
passé à l'état pour ceux qui en ont un
et les gens ne le feront pas pour les
autres et ils n'iront pas dans les
établissements soumis aux passes
sanitaires ils renverront leur
abonnement dans les salles de sport
cinéma etc
le boycott général pour forcer ces
établissements a demandé à exiger du
gouvernement macron le point de cette
folie la fin du pass de la honte
voilà pour et les revendications je vous
rappelle que depuis mercredi et bien se
passe sanitaire est obligatoire pour
avoir accès par exemple à certains lieux
à culturel c'est le cas notamment des
cinémas
merci et c'était là pour tout ces prêts